oh my goodness
welcome to winners Wednesday the first
ever online international people that
we've had on the program oh man you guys
are so awesome and I follow you like
crazy on Facebook and you're like
property gurus and I just had to have
you on the channel because I know when
you started I know I was a big part in
helping you guys get started initially
again over Skype so what are you guys
just introduce yourselves a little bit
just tell us what you guys doing wait
from what your strategy is okay so my
name is and we have been investing we
actually took it seriously the timing we
had to call with you and we found the
video I mean how long was that
tell us 2015 yeah yeah you were like the
first because I remember when we spoke
and you were talking about are you gonna
invest in England legal invest in Canada
and and we had quite a long like session
and and I'm sure that that was almost
five years ago so time flies yes yeah
and ever since I mean we've really
decided to focus on investing in real
estate as well as focusing on business
growth so we've kind of been doing that
and basically setting up our businesses
so that they generate cash flow and then
take that cash flow and dump it in real
estate because we see the value in
having the asset and one of the things I
really wanted to pick your brains on in
this call is the differences between
investing in in Canada and the UK and
kind of why you decided to invest in
Canada what the pros and cons are I know
you even came down to the crash course
we spent a couple days with me and the
team so just just almost fun to figure
out other state is it's similar but the
strategy is the same is there completely
different world I mean what do you guys
think it's a bit similar it's not you
know all like you know the same and
that's the reason why we came to the
crash course because we wanted to learn
from you and understand how to tackle
the UK market
so when you look at things like for
example you the you talking about the
HMOs for example we've got to learn how
to structure an HMO and all that stuff
right and here in Canada that HMO is
basically kind of like you know people
we call it like room rentals or boarding
home or different things and but the
things that you had to check out like
for example we found out that the
consul's tax the city council tax or
whatever you call it it's paid by the
tenant right whereas here in Canada it's
paid by the landlord so there was just a
bit of things that were different but at
the same time the whole real estate game
is the same it's just you know a bit of
difference but most of the time
everything is the same yeah sure so Gigi
corner feel then like the majority the
majority of the strategy is the same but
it's just a case of adapting and sort of
applying what can be applied definitely
yep yeah scope is the same but it's just
like a little thing that needs to be
changed and I would say um one thing I
found was different was that in the UK
um you can't get a HMO house until
you've got your own property correct
know exactly but else yes so that was
the biggest change because in Canada if
you want to invest you go and invest
they um relief is on okay so you've got
to get your own home and keep that and
then you can start buying real estate so
we've kind of gone on and you know gone
full force and buying investment
properties incredible guys tell me over
over the five years like what how what
people your portfolio up to how much
money are you making now in property so
um in we became we became full-time in
real estate four years ago that wasn't
20 2016 that's when like we really went
full time and we basically replaced
Colleen's income Colleen used to work
and she used to used to make almost six
figures so we actually made more than
six figures in 20 I think two years
later
that we became full time and then
Killeen actually managed to create a job
so we managed to get clean off her job
and then try a new market which was
Edmonton at the time so you know and
right now like we are still in the six
figures and but now we are also
investing in the United States so you
know we are building a portfolio like
that you can actually get a mortgage
easier with the job so Zeb and I both
started self-employed and then it was
like okay we want to get into real
estate but it's like well one of us has
to get a job so an order first build our
portfolio and be able to get those
mortgages one of us had to have a job
and I was like okay well I'll go I'll
basically make the most possible so we
could carry the most and then once he
got his years under his belt and he was
able to show that on his taxes he can
afford to carry more mortgages that's
and I was also able to be like okay well
we don't need my job anymore now let's
switch it up and people that say it's
okay for you guys because you know you
you're working you're getting paid six
figures I'm save lots it's fine for you
but then what about me who's not
necessarily earning six figures who
hasn't any money to start with all you
say to people like that so I would say
when we started we actually came to this
you know little city with nothing like
with her back I came with her back my
wife came with the bag we had no car
nothing all right
so we started working at McDonald's for
example I waited McDonald's and you know
I did three four jobs to build us up to
a certain situation where we could
actually have money for a first down
payment for a home yeah so I would say
that's you know when people say things
like that is an excuse not to actually
pursue their dreams because you can do
it right if you put your mind to it you
can do it when you make excuses you
never accomplish your goals and your
mopane than anyone else
push through tough times success comes
from those success comes through those
who push through the pain yeah
yeah yeah oh so you're saying you came
from Zimbabwe right yeah so we came from
Zimbabwe like 2001 so you came to just
like a couple bags working to McDonald's
and then what you saved up enough money
from working at McDonald's to buy a
house so no McDonald's and three other
jobs okay so what how did you do that
how did you say you realize that this 24
hours in the day yeah and if you work
those hours out and you break it down we
started with the goal of raising $5,000
each look was that saying you know we're
all gonna bring in five thousand dollars
each at the end of the month so that
means sharping whatever skills you have
starting whatever extra side gig you
could get anything that will generate
income to get you towards that financial
goal yeah
and then once we did then use that money
to buy a bigger business that was able
to bring in more funds so it wasn't just
you know McDonald's you know started
hustling doing that it's just about
bringing more income I don't know how
did you bring in more income so you say
you're working and you're trying to save
up as much as you can to put it into a
business what was your first business so
our first business was a driving school
so part of our moving process was to
move to a place where we were able to
get more opportunities yeah and we were
able to get more opportunities in a
community a smaller community that we
were able to start business ventures I
graduated in business and my family's
business so that's pretty much comes
naturally to me
so when zem is working at the striving
school you know my mom was like hey why
don't you open your own so our first
thing was we don't want to step on toes
you know and maybe not but then the
opportunity presented itself we have
saved up ten thousand dollars and tried
to buy a house and we got denied because
our credit was bad we also didn't have
you know enough funds to carry the
entire downpayment so we thought okay
well let's say this money towards
starting a business and start the
driving school so that started
generating enough income for us that led
to our next business we then started a
security business that brought in even
more money
so now we
had a lot more income that we were able
to bring in and we're able to save up
20% of the down payments okay yeah and
that's when you then what your first
house so your basically your first house
that you bought and what came from
basically just really hard work
discipline saving how did you go from
that because I think that's when we kind
of connected I think you're about to buy
I just bought your first house how did
you go from that to then scam in that
because I know now I mean I don't know
exactly what you're earning zone stuff
but it's obvious that you live in a very
good life you drive fancy Range Rovers
you know you're clearly live a good life
you got it man so how did you go from
that first house say five six years ago
to then scaling things up to a much
bigger level
so basically when we got the first house
this was an eye-opener for us okay so we
we we got a bungalow where we could
basically suite it up and we made rooms
at the bottom it was its own you know
unit at the bottom and three three three
bedrooms and we talented it okay and we
were living upstairs so we were living
upstairs for free because our tempers
were paying a lot of bills and our
mortgage and stuff like that so that was
an eye-opener like oh my goodness you
know so now we had so much cash in our
pockets me at business running we have
you know working income as well and then
from there we just couldn't figure out
like how can we scale it how can you
bring it like you know to make it into a
bigger business yeah and at that time we
managed to get into an educational
institution
um and mentor basically we got a mentor
in Canada that got us to a point where
we learn so many things and from there
oh man we just scaled it to a different
level like we did you know a seed we've
had a couple of properties we went out
of province out of state we came to UK
and then we are in the States right now
so it all stems from getting educated
and that's the reason why we came to UK
and became to your seminar because we
realize that you have to get education
for you too
to scale up yeah and I think people
don't realize that if actually want to
treat real estate investing like a
business and not a hobby
you've gotta actually put the time and
effort into building a business right if
you want to be a doctor you go to med
school a lawyer you go to law school but
a lot of people think I could just watch
Samuels YouTube videos here on my couch
in Canada and know how to buy a house
there but we quickly realize that if we
actually wanted to take this seriously
it started by buying a ticket flying
down and coming to see you and you know
what I'm always humbled by people that
fly in and it's a lot of pressure for me
as well because when people are flying
in from Australia in India in America
and Canada it's like jeez you know two
days I've got a really make account and
hopefully it was really worthwhile and
and it was I find it funny on the chat
when people like oh you know I'm like
two hours away when are you gonna be
closer to me I'm like I like on an
entire different continent and I flew
down for this if you don't see the value
you're not ready to grow so tricky next
to what you're doing for now so true
thank you guys I love you so much so so
scaling then what were the key things
that you did what were like if you were
talking to someone now who had maybe one
or two houses living rent free done
really well like you guys did but they
wanted to then grow that to a whole
nother level what are some of the key
things that you that you did that you
implemented from my training or from
other people's training that really took
you to the next level I think the first
thing that we learnt um from you and
also another from from our other mentor
was you have to narrow down your why why
do you want to do what you want to do
right so once you have that then you can
grow your business to whatever level you
want it to be so after narrowing down
our why like I think at a time we had we
got to about five properties and then
from there we're financially free but
then it was like okay do we continue
growing or do we just stop here right
and then we basically came down to like
you know what we want to create a legacy
for our kids you know we want to be able
to create
as well that can last for three
generations or more so from then we
basically then you know scaled to a
different level but some of the skills
that we used basically was you know how
to get mortgages right how to get
mortgages beyond a six properties we
networked with a lot of people who had
you know the same vibes as us seem like
mindedness and we still continue to
learn we didn't stop learning we still
continue to learn and all that helped us
to bring our business to a different
level
I like touched on on how like and I
realize that our Y can change because
our initial Y was so that I could quit
my job
however we outgrew that Y and we need to
we need it to find another reason to
keep us going okay well now that I've
quit my job what next do we just said to
be like we're good here but we had to
keep evolving and being like okay what's
the new reason why do we need to keep
pushing when we don't feel like it cuz
now that we're financially free we could
actually just sit down and do nothing
and we did that for a bit and we're like
okay well that was fun now let's do
something else cuz we Respimat were more
fulfilled doing a lot of real estate
talking to people connecting and really
helps us grow that's great so with those
five properties then that enabled you to
quit your job which is just incredible
what were they were they were they all
hate your nose with a family homes were
they apartments we had three HMOs and
then we had two single-family at the
time they called a pre-construction
where you buy into the building so um
when a building is looking to get our
job yeah a developer will give you the
best deals because they have to reach a
certain quota in order for the bag to
finance them so we were able to
negotiate a good deal on that property
get an off plan and when the building
went up it had gone up in value so we
were able to get extra income from that
to invest in our next deal so one of the
strategies that we used some well is a
refinance okay so we'll get a property
that's you know underutilized and then
we'll add value to it and
and the value will go up and they'll
refinance to check that money we buy
another property that's great I mean
it's really funny because a lot of the I
know in America as well a lot of
strategies in the UK and then in Canada
or America that they're the same but
they just call different things
everything's the same but it's just got
different names and as long as you can
just learn the lingo it's it's pretty
much the same thing so now that's
awesome so if you if you were starting
over would you still it would you start
out in Canada still or would you start
in America or the UK what do you think
is the best country to invest in I would
start in wherever I'm located the one
thing I picked up from the UK where's
the rent rent and strategy this was
something that does happen in Canada we
just did not know about it so coming
into the UK and finding out oh you can
actually rent to rent there goes the
excuse if I do not have enough money to
purchase a house yeah so that was an
eye-opener because at some point you'll
run out of time or money and it got to a
point where it's like okay do we want to
be raising consistently raising money or
waiting for a business to bring in money
and we're like wait rent to rent why can
we not even continue to do that - girl
portfolio yeah is that something that
you have you implemented when twin stars
in Canada we've started doing it a
little bit uh we basically rented where
we live so we would rent and then you
know me and the kids will travel
somewhere else and I would start are
renting out rooms and that's kind of how
we started because we were gone from
eggs so it's like okay well why don't
you try to rent out rooms and let's see
how this goes that's kind of building us
a like almost like lifestyle went to
rent business right yes that's awesome
so what's next then I mean you find
actually free what sort of them what so
you said you were branching into America
now as well what what's the plan for the
next few years this year I mean we made
a new resolution of actually getting
some properties in the States in January
and then between March and April we
managed to get two properties in Arizona
and in Phoenix Arizona and we're doing
short-term rentals there things like
Airbnb VRBO and stuff like that and the
properties are doing quite well
and we're going back next month we're
going to Ohio and it's gonna be a
game-changer you know there's a lot of
things happening over there and it's
going to be very I think this is going
to be unlike scale we're gonna invest in
Ohio a lot scale because things are
really really looking really good over
there it's pretty affordable so the
entry point of real estate I know when
you went to the states I think you take
something like New York which was like
that's like one of the most expensive
places to go to the state maybe more to
the states you know we could take a look
at it a bit more and for us it's
convenient because it's right next door
yes
so that got us thinking like you know it
okay the Canadian market where we are is
a bit pricey but for what we would put
as a downpayment we could actually buy a
house in the States
yeah so we started looking at the ohio
market where you could get a property
for like 50,000 u.s. you could put in
20,000 and you could get a hundred ten
thousand out of it so you could find us
that over a hundred thousand and get
more money out to do the next project
okay America Canada it's the same
strategies sometimes different names
sometimes it's the implementation
slightly different the rules might be
slightly different
what would you say the key things are
the differentiate the people that are
successful because a lot of people
watching my I have a very high Canada
rate they watch my videos there's a lot
of people some kind of hungry states for
sure my videos what's the difference
between the people that are successful
they're the same things and the
difference is the people that have
success successful are doers all right
they don't shocking the information and
keep on watching your videos and over
and over again and actually don't go out
and do that right and then most people
that are successful are able to
basically just slow down a little in
terms of like for example we rent where
we leave right we don't you know
the properties that we buy we don't live
there we rent rent out our properties
that we buy but then where we leave
we'll rent ourselves so some people are
not able to do that right they want to
have their own you know living space
they want to actually say I own my house
and all that stuff but those are like
strategies that successful people use
they are willing to wait sometimes for a
bigger picture you're right for them to
get there but the most important thing
is being a doer wait don't wait we've
got a friend who you know like you
everything like he knows more about real
estate than we did when we started
however his knowledge was never applied
so we were able to be like oh there's a
rent to read strategy and we're like
okay tell me Martin we're gonna do it
and we're gonna learn as we go
yeah where has this friend of like okay
I want to know from the beginning tell
me from the start
rent to read who's house am i renting
where is it located what do I do with it
okay what's what happens if my lease
doesn't stack you know so you gotta be
ready to dive in and at times learn on
the go right learn as you continue to
grow and that's how people are
successful you fall more times than you
could count but it's that's part of
making it that's great I think if I
learn to drive if you read this there
right and then you've got to actually
get in the car and if you can read the
theory for everyone everyone everybody
means you can live in the car with an
instructor who can slam the emergency
brake on if needed but you've got to
actually that's also okay so talk to me
a little bit then about HMOs in Canada
so specifically in Canada what are the
rules are there is there a lot of red
tape you said it was something that you
can you can do first time around
just give us some top tips around
average that's with you know seeing that
this value in a home sometimes it's like
the properties that we get they they
underutilized so when we get in there we
basically you know putting value we add
rooms for example if we get a property
that is four bedrooms our magic number
is two
87 okay cuz seven then we make a lot of
cash flow there so we get in there we
look we get permits from the city we do
sketches and stuff like that and then we
get the builders in and the contrast
Azim and once I think it takes about two
months max to get everything set up
and then from there would have already
decided who we went to we want to rent
you is it students is it professionals
oh whatever so we usually stick to
professionals and this has really
increased our business from when we
started because we realize that
professionals especially in the city
that you know we live in
they are very responsible people we
don't have to deal with things like
parties and all that stuff so once you
know we decided wanting to get
professionals we have been doing this
for the past four four years now and
they you know we've not had you know
these other you know horror stories that
we have had about people doing boarding
homes or HMOs and stuff like that
because of that strategy that we decided
to use and it's not like I find there's
not a lot of red tape in Canada because
there's two strategies you could get a
single-family home which we call a
bungalow where you've got a lower and an
upper and what you do is you create the
upper into its own suite so into its own
residence and then the lower into
another so in total you could do seven
rooms and those two but you also have
the option to let it out as individual
units but you can also do a
single-family home and achieve the same
so there isn't a lot of red tape however
it's important to do the research
because Canada so big they may allow it
in one part of Canada but not in another
and from what we know so far it's easily
achieved because there's a lot of
student rentals going around the country
every city has its own rules so that's
great what possessed you them to jump on
a flight to come to the crash course
right that's a big commitment so
basically I think was in 2016
yeah I think those 2016 not early 2017
December we're just sitting then were
like you know what you know we need we
need a new goal and we have been talking
to some you know people that we mentor
that we're like we are afraid to invest
elsewhere they're like oh my goodness we
cannot like invest even out of province
and stuff like that right
so as the do is that we are like you
know what let's try something different
you know and UK since I mean we have
like family in UK well like you know
what let's try UK but then before we try
it
we knew the the importance of getting
educated yeah and you know we've heard
about you we looked you up on you know
on the under on the internet and also we
watched your videos so we're like you
know what it's best for us to actually
come to your crash course because then
at that point we'll have all the
information that we need that will help
us to get started
so we're like yeah there's no way we
could go to the UK without getting
educated yeah no we based our trip based
on when you were having your crash
course love that really cool I'm so glad
to see you succeeding stuff we also
we've got family connections as well
just thought I'd throw that out there is
a disclaimer because we've I think we
bumped into the wedding as well at some
point after our first call I think yeah
we started talking just like oh this
guy's doing real estate let's talk with
you later not blood relatives as people
might be able to see but great to be
related even though it might be far
distance and great to be you know share
company of other successful people I'm
really proud to be apart of that and
cheering you one of the way so maybe
we'll do a windows Wednesday party when
you when you're both billionaires in a
few years
final final piece of advice for anyone
listening that wants to be successful in
property um for me basically would be be
a doer you know if you decide that
property is for you and that's what you
want to do
and go out there and actually make
things happen and the most important
thing is to know your why why you want
to be into property why do you want to
get into property because property these
ups and downs you know when you are down
that Y appeals will help you to be able
to go up so y know your why and be a
doing and mine would be it it's okay to
do your research on all these gurus who
are teaching real estate but try not to
focus on the negative cuz everyone has
you know a hater we'd be like well you
know what I didn't like this about that
person but if you cling on to that
reason if this is why will not obtain
knowledge from this person you are
losing out because that person is still
moving along with their life so if you
connected somebody and they've got
valuable information to share just put
everything else on the back burner and
focus on what they are saying it may not
be you know it I've heard this and that
and that but also realize that I want to
achieve these goals for myself and this
is the person you can get me there so
that is where I'm gonna go yeah that's
great really I guess you can learn from
anyone and sometimes people don't even
like me they don't like mine you know
oh he's arrogant or whatever but the
bottom line is you've got to get what
you can from people and then go and
implement it so nah bro guys thank you
so much for coming on the show in the
first ever international winners
Wednesday because I didn't think you
don't want Skype I always thought oh we
have to be up but actually we have
online these days so peace out and god
bless you and I look forward to see you
continue to smash in prop say thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]